In the past,
you've seen Grant teach you
how to make a rope maker,
and how to make
a few types of DIY rope.
Well today, we are going
to test those kinds of rope.
We're going to see
how much weight they can take
before they break.
[Music]
Guys, you've seen
Grant make rope before.
You've even learned
how to make a rope maker
from him, and today,
we're going to put
that to the test.
This one is made from cord.
We've also got some sisal twine,
and finally, a rope made
out of soda bottles.
So to test these types of ropes,
we can't just say, oh,
we pulled this hard
until it snaps.
So, we've got
an industrial scale.
It's a crane scale.
We're going to secure the rope
in between this scale
and a truck,
and then start driving away.
We're going to film this screen,
and see how high it gets right
before the rope gives out.
Maybe the ropes will snap.
Maybe the ropes will
stretch to the point
where they're not securing
anything anymore.
We just want to see
how high the scale gets
before that happens.
That should tell us
how strong our rope is.
48.
40-- 50.
You hit 50.
Almost 51.
[Music]
43.
43 pounds, not bad.
Okay, you got like
10 pounds on me.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to take three kinds
of DIY rope that Grant
has shown you in the past,
and we're going to put them
on a powerful scale,
and pull on them with a truck
to see how long they last
before they snap.
[Music]
Almost 60.
Okay.
So our powers combined
doesn't do much.
Once we've made some rope
that we can hold onto,
I think we'll be able
to do a lot more than that.
Yeah.
The problem right now is
that it's less about strength,
and more about what
your fingers can take.
[Music]
We've made all
of our types of rope.
We've got them out here,
and we've got
two big old trucks,
and we're gonna pull them
and see what happens to them.
First off, best bet,
which one do you think
is gonna be strongest?
I kind of think
that the the triple braided
sisal rope is going
to be the strongest.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think the Mason twine is
actually going to be stretchier,
but the sisal twine is going
to be a lot of stronger.
All right, so we have
a single piece of the sisal,
a single piece of
the Mason twine,
then for both of those,
we've got three twists
braided together,
which is actually six strands,
because it's three
times going there and back,
and then we have three
of those twisted together,
as well as the soda bottle rope
that Grant made,
and we're going
to test all of them.
Just want to point out,
we've made a quick
modification to our scale.
You can't really see too well
what's going on necessarily,
but this is a GoPro
that's just facing the numbers,
and we don't know.
This might twist or something
as we're pulling on it,
and this way,
the GoPro is sort
of locked in place.
It's always facing the screen.
We should always be able to see
what's on the screen.
It's filming at
a high frame rate,
so right before the rope breaks,
we should see the maximum
pull strength that it gets to.
First up is the single
strand of Mason line.
We'll see what it gets to.
I bet that
immediately just flips.
Oh, yeah.
[Music]
All right, you're
starting to lift.
Hey, it lifted it up.
All right, you can add
a little bit more tension.
[Music]
Camera's spinning
around like crazy.
Done.
I think it did actually
break at the knot.
Doesn't matter how strong
your rope it is
if the knot can't take it.
Most of the time
you're not going to just have
two plates squishing down
on top of your rope
as you pull away.
So that should be our first one.
Yep.
Let's move on to the sisal.
[Music]
It's lifting.
It broke.
So that broke very quickly.
I'm interested to see
what that got to.
All right.
So we tested
our individual strands.
Next is our three strand rope,
and we're going
with the sisal twine this time,
because we think it's going
to break faster just
after that initial tests.
So these little
u-shaped brackets,
they tightened down quite a bit.
This is what we're going
to be using for everything,
other than the single strands,
just because we don't have
to tie knots this way.
We've got liftoff.
Better than the last one.
[Music]
Stop.
This wasn't as tight as I
was hoping it would,
but it's still
snapped the twine.
Yeah.
So, I think it was
a good result.
We'll see once we get
to the bigger ropes,
but now I'm banking
on the Mason twine.
That's lit.
[Music]
It is lifting.
It is stretching.
[Music]
Keep going.
Huh?
So it's actually putting...
>> Stop!
>> pressure?
I'm not sure what failed.
I think it was just the rope.
This looks very broken.
Yeah.
Now that I would say definitely
at a much higher strength.
So using these little
you bracket shape pieces,
one of them is now missing.
Because I think
when the rope broke, it kind
of got launched somewhere,
and we haven't yet found
where that somewhere is.
[Music]
I got it.
No more rope attached though.
[Music]
I don't think it needs
much interaction,
but I'm going to back
up more because...
I don't want to
snap and hit you.
Now, we started
launching metal pieces.
[Music]
It is lifting.
It is stretching.
I hate this.
It is broken.
It broke.
Sure enough.
It just keep breaking near where
we're putting tension on it.
But..
That is extremely common.
Most cords, ropes,
tethers will break
where you have a knot,
just because it's being pinched.
There's extra pressure
right there.
I still think
we're getting good data.
All right, time for what we
assume to be our strongest.
[Music]
We have liftoff.
Stretching.
Stretching more.
Broke.
Nice.
Holy cow.
This stuff is crazy strong.
So I think these two broke,
and then this one stayed on,
and just kept stretching,
and then it broke as well.
Yeah.
All right.
I think this is
our strongest one,
but we still got
one more to test.
We do.
We have our soda bottle rope,
and I don't know much
about the strength
of the soda bottle rope.
But we want to know.
I believe Grant hung
from the soda bottle rope.
So that's some amount of weight.
That's an indication,
but it's not an exact number.
So now we want to get
an exact number.
[Music]
I do think it'll break,
but I think it
will stretch a lot
before it breaks.
All right, let's find out.
[Music]
Lifting.
Stretching.
Wow.
Holy cow!
Broken.
[Music]
Looks like we just had one,
one of our little ropes
doing all the work here.
One broke last.
Yeah.
Same thing that happen
with the other one.
Like two of them broke,
and then it stretched
a little bit more,
and then it broke more.
Very cool.
Let's take a look
at our results.
All right, reviewing footage.
First up, the string.
The Mason twine,
one strand of it.
I think it reached five pounds.
[Music]
Wow.
It can pull more weight
than I can pull just with the,
the two bars together.
41-40--.
Oh, it hit 49.
That was a 49.
48 to 49.
49.
Yeah.
>> 49 and then...
>> In just a second.
All right, do you think
this one pulled more or less?
I'm thinking way less.
Well, remember how
quick it snaps.
Yeah.
It broke.
It didn't--
>> It didn't even get completely--
>> Didn't even get tight, yeah.
9.
It hit 9, 10.
Oh yeah.
It's breaks at 10.
The 10 flashed up there.
I don't think it's
always that weak.
I think we had like a weak spot.
So it's that--
It's made from fibers.
Just these super
thin fibers twisted together.
Overall, it's decently strong,
but there are
sometimes weak points.
And I think,
we maybe had a knot
tied on a weak point,
because ten pounds
is pretty little.
It did obviously break without
even pulling the line tight.
So, it might have really
just been 10 pounds on it.
This is the sisal rope,
the six strands of it.
Did hold tight,
little bit of stretching.
And then snap.
30, 50, 60--
It hit--
Oh.
I think I saw--
Like 130.
139 maybe?
39, 139.
I think it might be switching
from 20 to 30 but,
we have one backward 6, 9.
Moving on
to the Mason twine.
So six strands of the Mason
twine twisted together.
All right, 189.
So 129-139 up to 189
with the Mason twine.
Just one was about 130.
We don't know exactly,
because our scale
didn't get perfect reading.
But about 130.
3 times that,
do you think's going to be 390?
It's stretching.
Oh, but this--
It's just slide, and snap.
The slide is what's
interesting on this one.
>> Oh, I think that's--
>> 299.
That hit 299.
Yeah, I think we're
at 293 there.
Yeah, that's 293.
All right, so not three
times as much.
Almost up to 300 pounds.
Those points where
it's binding together,
where it's actually
being attached, those are going
to be a little bit weaker.
So it's not fully as strong as
three times the strength of one,
but it's quite a bit stronger.
It's more than double.
For a homemade rope
out of twine...
300 pounds is,
you can be able to move a lot
of stuff at 300 pounds.
Yeah.
You're getting a
good strong rope.
So stretchy.
Oh my goodness.
Stretching more.
Broke.
Nice.
I remember, two
of them broke first,
and there just
ones stretched out--
Just holding on.
Just stretching a lot.
What'd you get?
But before,
when the first one broke,
we had a high point
of like 390 in there, I think.
I think it's that...
389.
Almost 300,
and then almost 400
for the Mason twine.
Not quite there.
But not bad.
It's pretty serious rope.
And now we've got one left,
the soda bottle.
Where you think
the soda bottle rope opens up?
I don't even know where to begin
to guess on this one.
Lifting.
That's so stretchy.
Oh my goodness.
Just goes out of frame.
Stretching.
Wow.
I was kidding, but it does.
Broken.
Oh, it stretched a ton.
Wow.
Down.
No way.
That's it.
Like 440--
The soda bottle rope
is our strongest rope.
That's soda bottles.
It was thicker.
It was still a lot thicker too.
But it doesn't matter.
That's, that's volume, not mass.
That's crazy.
I did not think the soda bottle
rope would be that strong.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video,
or you want to watch it again,
click up here at the top.
Click down there
if you want to see
what the internet thinks
you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun.
Be safe.
See you tomorrow.